what's going on guys this is rob and we
are back
with sword yes we are getting caught up
on all the x-men stuff so a little bit
of a refresher here for those of you
guys who are a little behind on this uh
dawn of x was like the official
launch of x-men after house and powers
of x and then dawn of x
ended with ten of swords and now we're
in reign of x now we did cover the
beginning of sword issue number one
and that led directly into the events of
king and black so honestly
uh all the stuff we covered in king of
black basically covers everything that
more or less appears in sword not overly
important but the end of issue number
one
basically concluded with a group called
the six right these these kind of select
beings who each served a unique purpose
among the mutant race
being sent into what was basically the
realm of the cosmic entities
in order to retrieve an artifact and
then they returned with it and then we
basically pick up here with issue number
five or issues five and six now one of
the things that goes on is we pick up
with the
what you can call the snarks technically
they're called the the z
zenricks i don't know 25 years reading
comics man i've never been able to
pronounce these guys names right right
they first appeared with power pack back
in 1984.
they're okay i mean they're obsessed
with like collecting mutant powers
basically is really all it is and just
kind of enhancing it that way but they
are in effect a kind of warring race
that's composed of a bunch of different
tribes so imagine if like the spartans
here on earth were not gathered together
in sparta but were found in like
different locations around the world and
they always were against each other but
they were all unified by a singular
emperor now the way this works is that
each one of the factions is basically
ruled by a queen and in the case that
the emperor dies the factions end up
engaging in what's called a snark war
and that basically leads to the the son
of the ruling faction becoming the new
emperor now the reason why this is so
horrifying from around the universe for
a lot of people who are out there is
because when it comes to the snark wars
they take no prisoners right they will
like literally
conquer whole worlds and use them as
like a staging ground
to kind of continue their war against
themselves and everybody gets a piece of
that pie whether they want it or not
that's just the way it is
and so because of that with them being a
pretty powerful and interstellar race
all of them going to war with each other
is pretty extreme the issue here is
one of them is basically taken out by an
assassin and that's going to be the kind
of thing that goes on among this race
now that's not an overly
important part here but it is a bit of
an important part and we'll talk about
why that matters here in a minute
instead what we do is we switch over to
fabian quartets right now fabian cortez
we had talked about him in the first
sword video and he got his claim to fame
by being an acolyte right and the
acolytes are basically these people out
there who just believed wholeheartedly
in magneto fabian cortez was one of
those and in fact he was kind of the
the guy who principally worshiped
magneto more so than anybody else now in
the aftermath of x-men vol 2 and the
years that came after that with the
various x-men stories that marvel wrote
the character of fabian cortez began to
change a lot
so much so that he was almost completely
removed from his role when he originally
appeared and became somebody vastly
different
more recently he was brought on board
the sword uh really their base of
operations called the peak as kind of
like their head of medicine just because
of the fact that his power is to heal
people but ultimately he was killed
during the events of king in black and
of course they've resurrected him here
the funny thing is that for the most
part feminine cortez is kind of a dick
and no one really likes him at all like
nobody likes him
so much so that whenever a person is
usually resurrected
uh during the events of cocoa assuming
they're not resurrecting like 10 at one
time
then that person kind of receives a bit
of a resurrection party right kind of
like you know hey congratulations
it's good to have you back that kind of
thing damien cortez doesn't get that no
one's there except for jean grey
and she's like the council wants to talk
to you and that's it right it's like the
least ceremonious resurrection process
ever so that gives you an indication of
how much they hate this guy when he gets
to the council though
the reason why they have such a strong
disdain is made quite apparent
because he puts on this sort of
grandiose speech right i mean the guy's
standing naked pulls his hair back into
a bun and basically starts talking to
them about the idea of
eliminating humanity now it's kind of an
interesting thing because from his
perspective
the second law that exists out there
among krakow which is
you cannot harm humanity is a backwards
law and a lot of this is rooted in
fabian cortez
extreme views that he's had over the
course of his life which is humanity
gets what it deserves right that
humanity has routinely screwed over the
mutant population
so why should we do them any favors
right why should we keep from
eradicating them right in a lot of ways
it's kind of magneto's old ideas that
have been brought to bear here and
that's one of the elements of fabian
cortez
that never changed over the course of
his history in marvel comics right when
he first showed up he was avidly against
the entire human population
he was wholly pro-magneto right magneto
was right that when it comes to the
human race
humanity needs to end right humanity
will either end because of its own
choices because of the fact that it
obliterates itself in its own conflicts
or humanity will end because we will
destroy it at the end of the day
we as the mutant population are the
rightful dominant race
and and that's kind of the funny thing
he's like i'm not approaching that from
the perspective of just believing that
we're holier than that i'm not
approaching it from the perspective of
i've somehow given myself that authority
he's like just
even from an evolutionary standpoint
that's the case he says you yourself
charles xavier had advocated and argued
on multiple occasions
that we are the next stage in human
evolution and if the human race really
wanted to peacefully co-exist with the
mutant population
we wouldn't have to worry about people
infiltrating krakowa and trying to take
us out
we wouldn't have to worry about
organizations like orcas
none of that would happen and so he says
like at the end of the day like they're
going to die
right if anything we're acting is is not
really he doesn't really say kavorki in
a traditional sense but he's like if
anything
we're just aiding them in their own
suicide or we're aiding them in their
own deaths they're going
to die right just because of the fact
that humans don't have the ability to
resurrect themselves and they have all
these instruments and
weapons of war right these giant war
machines they will obliterate themselves
in due time now here's the funny thing
about this
cortez makes some good points he makes
some very
very good and salient points humanity
will inevitably end
right it will come to an end and so why
not simply just get them out of the way
now now of course
one of the things that that's the entire
basis of kokoa is that kind of hidden
plan
right that's only known among more
mctaggart charles xavier and magneto
nobody else really knows not even we
know the underlying current and what
they're actually planning here
presumably it's to to prevent the
extinction of the mutant population
at the hands of regular humanity as well
as the
really advanced humans that we know are
in the vault as we saw it play out in
house and powers of x the problem is
that in the middle of all that you end
up having this kind of
last individual who's basically killed
at least as far as the the zen rex go
this last person that stands in the way
of this this queen kind of ruling or at
least for her offspring going to be the
one that becomes a new emperor and of
course
that person is killed by amelia vaughn
now amelia vaught has a
long long history of marvel comics
the reality is unless you're a big fan
of the history of charles xavier
her name is largely lost on you and even
then when this particular one this this
you know person right guylar
when they believe that like the day is
saved amelia kills them too right and
there's a reason why
these individuals are being
systematically hunted down but amelia to
kind of give you guys a quick little
explanation here amelia was at one point
a love interest of charles xavier she
ended up defecting when the whole thing
with the acolytes and all that stuff
popped off but she's been a kind of
on-again off-again ally of charles
xavier and the x-men
more enemy than ally but she's still
kind of been there as an ally from time
to time
the fact that she's here indicates that
she is you know gonna have a much larger
role in what's going on and in fact she
is right she's going to have a huge role
in what's happening but to to kind of
wrap up that little bit of a plot thread
there right with these you know zen rex
aliens kind of being eliminated uh that
amelia's the one who's doing it right
now a lot of that's also just
mama kind of wrapping up the idea of
this this alien race in reality appeared
in the old power pack stories and it's
just kind of been lingering around ever
since there's no real reason for their
existence there's no purpose for them
outside of the role that they might play
later on uh which of course we'll talk
about a bit but
what you end up getting here is this
question you know kind of switching back
to fabian cortez
this question is posed by peeper now
people of course we talked about him in
the first sword video he's a
long-standing member of magneto's kind
of brotherhood of evil mutants him and
magneto have known each other for a long
time
so much so that magneto trusts him
implicitly and so they kind of ask the
question of fabian cortez what's your
mutant name and fabian cortez sticks
with the idea
my name is cortez my family's descended
from royalty that we bent continents to
our whim that i was shunned and i was
exiled my my sister and i we were
basically cast aside because of the fact
that we weren't really deemed to be part
of humanity because we were mutants we
were ostracized for that reason but at
the end of the day
i am still quartets right that name
belongs to me and i took it upon myself
the reason why this line of questioning
and this conversation between
peeper and fabian cortez matters is
because fabian cortez does not really
see himself as part of the mutant
population because he doesn't identify
as one
if you if he truly identified as part of
the mutant population he would have cast
aside his human name like
everybody else has and then adopt his uh
his mutant name
unto himself magneto started off as just
magneto right but that's
officially his name now and that's the
point that peeper makes that a lot of
the names that we have now we have those
because they were call signs or they
were just monikers that we use at one
point along the line in our existence as
we fought against the x-men or for the
x-men
whatever the case is but we have taken
those those monikers those call signs
and we've adopted them
as our actual names because we recognize
as members of this mutant nation
we need to have that kind of mutant
individuality and so because of that in
reality
despite the salient points that he makes
fabian cortez's entire argument here
falls on deaf ears this is really
exemplified most when magneto
steps up and says today you talk of
murder right you talk of murdering
humanity you talk of killing humanity
wiping them off the face of the map
i know murder i have committed murder
countless times over the course of my
life
murder in the simplest terms is a choice
i have made that choice
many many times and the passion of an
instant and in the cold
calculated length but such choices were
made in a time
long past we are here and it is now if i
were to make that choice again
for any reason i would face exile and
face it
gladly for we must be a nation of laws
and he says i have listened to how you
suffered at human hands to your reasons
do me one favor cortez look me in the
eye and tell me that they're greater
than mine and the whole point behind
that right the whole point of magneto
making that case is for him to basically
say you come
to me with this argument of the terrible
things that you've had humanity do to
you and how humanity needs to end
not just because of what they've done to
you but because of what they've done to
other mutants but all this is rooted in
your pain but i am magneto
my pain is far exceeds yours right the
olympics of suffering
you know my pain exceeds yours the
things that humanity has put me through
exceeds yours right magneto talking
about his daughter anya who was
basically killed at the hands of
humanity but if magneto is able to cast
that aside
and and be a part of a nation of laws
why can't fabian cortes and if he's not
able to it's a choice he makes
that's the point he makes here right and
this shows up when you have fabian
cortez's argument
turns into one of desperation right he's
like you need me right you need me to be
part of your of your team right your
your sword team who goes into space and
and deals with these missions right
you're head of your science division you
can heal people
you need me you need me you need me
right it's one of these things where
they're almost kind of making this
argument of like we're going to dump you
in the hole right we don't need you
anymore and so when that happens and he
makes this case
suddenly you have amelia vaught who
shows up as well as this this young kid
who's referred to as
korra of the burning heart right and he
says i am fire in the soul and i am
murder in the dark
i am of oraco and he says i am here to
take your place i am your replacement
this is one of those instances when
krakow
is dipping into morocco and grabbing
those people and bringing them in
just as they said they would to kind of
unify a rocko
and krakowa to kind of turn them into a
singular organization right a singular
group now again for those of you guys
who are unfamiliar with morocco
make sure you check out my videos on uh
on ten of swords that will
clear it up for you as bright as day
right just because if we wanted to kind
of break it all down now
take 20 minutes to do so the long and
short is that the mutants of morocco are
basically
long-lost mutants and so bringing them
into the fold is kind of unifying these
places together
more so than that it turns out magneto
was just killing time until they got
here
until amelia and cora got here and then
it's just kind of like i mean it was
cool to let you talk fabian but i mean
you know like you're really here so we
can introduce you to your replacement
and let you know that like we're
basically just getting rid of you and at
that point they all blow them off i'm
gonna be honest man
it's a dick move right i mean they're
you have charles xavier who's talking to
amelia he's like hey girl we haven't got
caught up in a long time like you want
to get together she's like i mean we've
both really been busy but like if
there's nobody demanding your time he's
like no
nobody important and like family and
cortez is just standing there looking so
it kind of sucks right it's kind of a
kind of a crappy thing to do but more so
than that
what you do is you pick up here uh
really immediately after the fireworks
as we had during the x-men gala we were
kind of talking about how you had the
main conclusion to it we covered the
beginning and the close this is one of
those instances where we kind of tie
into it a lot of you guys said you
wanted to see that and so you kind of
have this bit of a discussion between
doctor doom and captain america right
now
this is one of the important things to
know about the sword comics is despite
the fact that it's largely tied into the
x-men universe it's not
wholly an x-men title it's not like new
mutants or x-factor or x-force where you
explicitly see
x-men related stuff you're gonna see a
lot of things outside of the x-men here
the conversation
between doctor doom and captain america
is one of them now the important thing
away from all this and and really
the reason why this matters is because
the illusion that or at least the
image that was given to them by emma
frost is kind of the conclusion to the
gala
really seems to show the jumps and the
leaps that the mutant population has
made
and this basically leads to this kind of
discussion about occupying mars right
this kind of thing about the mutant
population has basically found a way
to to stand on mars and that's when you
sort of switch directly to the peak and
you have this kind of coming together
with regards to this galactic council
now
everybody here who's part of these
galactic or at least part of the
galactic representatives it's big
right i mean you've literally got like
the chameleons here i always love the
chameleons right kofi white mane i love
the chameleons in marvel comics only
old fans will know what i'm talking
about like people who have been reading
comics for
probably too long as long as i have
anyway i've been reading comics for way
too long
but they'll know what i'm talking about
with the white mains right the
regellions uh the the xenryx empire that
kind of a thing the reason
why this zenerix empire happened the way
that it did and amelia bought was there
is because the reality is by eliminating
all the competition
and putting empress kuga in power what
it means now is its sword
has can can essentially call in a favor
right they're the ones that solidified
the the ability for empress kuga to
essentially take over they more or less
orchestrated a coup d'etat is really
what it is right wiped out the
competition
paved the way for her and her son to
conquer and that was it right now
they're an ally of kokoa so
again it's it's it's political but it's
pretty smart we've also got people here
like smasher of course who works for the
ciara empire but then you've got some
very familiar faces peter quill
right the peter cool star-lord you've
got richard ryder you know who's kind of
like he's supposed to be the earth
representative for the rest of the
universe but the whole reason why this
is called here and the whole reason why
they're there is because
what's happened here is sword has begun
the process
of terraforming mars and making mars a
habitable place
now the mutants of corcoa are not going
to live there instead
mutants of a rocco are going to occupy
there not all of them
but a pretty big chunk of them are going
to be staying there now the funny thing
is that when when this whole council's
called they're kind of like i mean this
is what you called us here for to tell
us that you terraformed a planet
we're empires who have been here for
millions of years we did that
millions of years ago right we've
conquered entire galaxies right and
you're telling us
about a single world and the whole thing
about about abigail brand kind of being
here is
no that's not why we called you here the
reason we called you here is because we
have discovered an element
an artifact a material that actually is
incredibly powerful we call it mysterium
we're the only ones in possession of it
but it's a meta material condensed from
certain exotic particles of course she's
not spilling the recipe to anybody
but she basically says if you want this
you can only get it from us
you guys know how krakow had basically
created medicines that prolong life
or cure any mental illness or disease
that's basically what's happening here
that by abigail brand
and sword locating and basically taking
this material
that is absurdly powerful absurdly
durable and can be used
for a multitude of different purposes
and then being the only ones in
possession of it what they're doing is
they're coming to this galactic table
with a bargaining chip and they say you
are
empires that have been around for so
long that have been around for millions
of years and you guys have interstellar
travel you guys have conquered multiple
worlds
earth in and of itself is largely a
backwater planet right i mean nobody's
really going to take us seriously
we're just now developing the ability to
achieve interstellar travel
kind of that conversation between doctor
doom and captain america where captain
america said that when he was thought
out he was asking tony stark about
whether or not humanity had like
traveled to mars or whether or not we
colonize other worlds and things like
that and tony stark's like not really
man
and so this is one of those instances
where despite earth being viewed as a
backwater planet
now they have a material that nobody
else in the universe has nobody else has
access to this
and so abigail brand says we will let
you guys have access to it but one
only in the amount that we allow you to
access to treat it like a currency so we
can call it the soul instead of like the
dollar or the nickel or something like
that we'll call it the saul because
basically earth exists in the sol system
and so it's a currency that's unique to
earth's solar system
and then three we want to be represented
right we want to be
seen as a viable contender out there in
the universe in terms of being
considered a real
incredible world and so when she says
like this this world this mar
this planet mars is no longer going to
be called mars it's called planet oracle
and she says are there any questions
boom enter doctor doom and doctor doom
comes strolling in here and says yes i
have questions like
this is the biggest question i have here
is why right what's the point of this
you're nothing more than a planner and a
schemer
everything you do is done for a
particular purpose to achieve a
particular goal but you say that earth
is a world that's unified or earth has a
singular
singular voice for you say but earth is
nothing more than a world that's
inhabited by a series of factions right
the faction of of china japan
india germany spain australia it's
nothing more than just a series of
individual nations all
vying for some measure of power humanity
is about as far from unified as anybody
can get
and now you're saying that this
extension of a fractured faction world
now exists on mars yet somehow a
singular person speaks for mars if
a singular mutant out there speaks for
the entirety of the martian population
then i would hear that voice i would
have that person stand before me right
now
and tell me who this king of mars is who
would speak for the entirety
of our solar system to the rest of the
of the of the known universe
and that's when you have this portal
that opens and basically this chick says
victor like you know what my name is and
many of you have heard it before right
the wind rider
she who swam with a conti i storm
am the region of mars storm basically is
the voice of the entire solar system
and not a better person to choose than
her right like literally
just like just the goddess of like life
itself right like what better person to
choose than storm
it's amazing dude it's so ridiculously
cool because you want to talk about
powerful man see here's the thing man
people who don't read comics they're
sleeping on the power storm man storm is
ridiculously op
because she controls weather patterns no
matter where she is it doesn't matter
what world she's on right and that's one
of the things that's kind of interesting
because marvel's
dabbled over the years but never
actually made it a mainstay of her
character
solar storms space storms right like
presumably
she can control those too and you've
seen instances wars happened
occasionally and her power has been
pushed to that level
but not in a not in a in a regular sense
i honestly think
that's what's gonna happen man now the
only real hold out from everything going
on here as far as like these galactic
societies the intergalactic empire
of wakanda right because remember
wakanda has long since been
been an intergalactic empire they're
like no we don't really need your your
your mutant metal right we don't really
need that i mean we have our own
technologies we have our own our own
stuff like there's really nothing you
have that we need the intergalactic
empire of wakanda is like the soul hold
out everybody else is on board and so
what you end up doing here is jumping to
magneto at about 3 15 in the morning
the celebrations are long since done
right it's over right the whole the
whole gala and everything's finished my
needle is just kind of chilling there
and and you know having a
shot here you go old friend kind of
talking to himself you know all the
power and all the stuff that you've
worked for
a little bit of a celebration for
himself when like one of the cohen gates
opens and here comes the scarlet witch
now here's the thing man
wanda is is is not allowed here right
she's i mean as far as the the mutants
like pretty much all the mutants are
concerned no one wants to see her right
and it makes perfect sense she literally
stripped 98
of them of all their power right like
house of m people haven't forgotten man
people have not forgotten the events of
house of m and and like decimation
right like all that stuff children's
crusade people have not forgotten that
right like wanda
is a cursed name among the mutant
population they despise her and so it's
one of those crazy things because when
when she's here talking to magneto
magneto had invited her and she went as
far as to say like i got your invitation
but i i just i couldn't face all these
people here right not after everything
that i've done
not after everything that i've said i
can't be here among these people and
even if i could they wouldn't have me
and that's one of the crazy things
because magneto kind of responds and
says did i ever tell you about my
daughter anya now here's the thing about
magneto's daughter audio those are guys
who don't know the story right
it's covered one in like the original
x-men stories done by
chris claremont and then you have like
classic x-men which was basically
reprints of the old school x-men stories
but like additional stuff was added in
because one of the things a lot of you
guys may not know is that when a writer
submits a story to marvel
editors go over it and they basically
cut out what they deem to be unnecessary
fluff classic x-men was putting a lot of
that stuff back in
or it was writers just writing in a
short little script of stuff they would
add in and then that was basically added
into the comic and then it was just put
out there right so again
it's kind of a cool little thing like a
director's cut for a movie or something
along those lines
and so what this means is that with
magneto's daughter anya
she was really the first daughter that
he had with magda and that there came a
time following world war
ii depending on what story you're
reading if you're reading uh like greg
pax magneto testament or you're reading
classic x-men
how it is magneto and magda met doesn't
really matter is usually kind of
kind of consistent across the board but
as far as anya went
that magneto had used the forger to
create a fake name for himself
and got work as in in just like a local
town during a moment of a heated
exchange between himself and his boss
he revealed that he had powers and then
left to go back home during that time
his boss and seemingly other people
around the town had learned that he was
a mutant and so they actually descended
on his home before he got there and set
his house on fire
and his daughter anya burned to death in
the process following that
he lost it he ended up just kind of
unleashing this this almost
electromagnetic pulse that actually
shut down the electrical impulses in
their brains and killed them all
following that his wife freaked took off
she ended up in one dagor mountain and
that's where you get quick silver and
scarlet witch now
after that it's bonkers it's marvel
retconned tomfoolery and well they're
not really as kids and all that kind of
stuff this introduces a
massive change right because one of the
big talking points that have been going
on when it came to the scarlet witch is
whether or not she was actually the
daughter of magneto
if you go and you read stories like
scarlet witch and vision like the
original four issue run by bill mantlow
it was like scarlet witch trying to
figure out whether or not magneto was
her actual dad as he claimed to be you
fast forward to the events of axis and
it turns out she's actually not his
child right that her and quicksilver are
not magnetos kits and that's one of the
things that kind of gets maintained here
that where he largely talks to her about
the mistakes he's made with his children
different things like that
she says like you know i'm not your
actual daughter and he says i know right
so it's not as though marvel changes and
said actually you are
again like you were my kid now because
you know marvel and marvel cinematic
universe the next man and you know like
it's not really it doesn't really play
out that way instead like what he
basically says here is i know you're not
my biological daughter but you're as
good as you might as well be right
what's real
is not always the same as what's true
and he says sometimes it takes two to
pretend
and so he says you are my daughter one
you will always be my daughter
even if not biology and blood but it's
one of these things where there's a kind
of of coming together between these two
right where
it's basically making up for all the
past misdeeds that happened between the
two of them
this is huge because what it does is it
kind of sets the stage for the return of
scarlet witch in the x-men line of
comics more so than that it's gonna make
a lot of sense out of her character in
the marvel cinematic universe so
with that being said guys we're gonna
bring this to an end thank you guys for
watching and i will catch you all later
peace